this course will help you master Lang
chain a revolutionary AI first framework
Lang chain enables developers to build
context aware reasoning applications by
linking large language models with
external data sources for advanced
natural language processing applications
starting with the basics of text
processing and vectorization and
advancing to the nuanced aspects of
laying chains expression language and
retrieval techniques you'll gain
hands-on experience in building real
world AI applications Tom chant
developed this course he is an
experienced developer and course creator
at scrimba hey there free code campers
and welcome to this interactive course
where you're going to learn how to use
Lang chain JS to build a context aware
chatbot that can answer questions on a
specific document we provid it we're
starting with the basics so you don't
need any prior experience with Lang
chain JS or even with AI the only
prerequisites for this course are a
knowledge of working with apis and
vanilla
JavaScript now Lang chain has a
reputation for a steep learning curve
but using its new expression language we
make the journey much
easier this is a Project based course
with challenges and that means you're
going to get your hands on the keyboard
writing code throughout and if you're
wondering how you can access the project
code don't worry we've got you covered
from the interact active version of this
course on sca.com you can pause the
video edit the code and run the projects
right there in your browser or you can
download the code from the scrims and
run them locally if you prefer the link
is in the description and one final
thing if you enjoyed this course do hit
the thumbs up right here on YouTube and
if you'd like to get in touch reach out
to me I'm on Twitter or X at TP chant
okay let's Dive In
hang chain to build aiiowed applications
I am super excited to bring you this
course on using one of the most
mind-blowing Technologies in the
emerging AI Universe we are going to
study embeddings we'll be working with
Vector stores we'll be building
templates and creating prompts from
those templates next we'll look at
setting up chains and we'll do that
using Lang chains expression language
which is a more expressive and
accessible way to write Lang chain we'll
be looking at the pipe method to join
elements of a chain together we'll be
retrieving data from a vector store and
then we'll use the runnable sequence
class which is a really cool way to
create complex chains in Lang chain and
there's loads more plus challenges this
is our project we are building a bot
which is knowledgeable on information we
give it so this bot is going to know all
about our platform sca.com and we're
going to feed it 3,000 words of
information and then we'll be able to
interrogate it on this information this
is one of the most powerful uses of AI
and it's a process that Lang chain makes
easy now in this course we're going to
focus on the Lang chain syntax the
project is built in vanilla JavaScript
and you're welcome to refactor it into
any framework or Library you wish I'm
assuming you have a solid knowledge of
vanilla JavaScript but you don't need to
be an expert if you've worked with apis
and asynchronous JavaScript a little bit
before you're going to be absolutely
fine
my name is Tom chant and I will be your
tutor for this course you can find me on
Twitter or X or whatever you want to
call it I am @ TP chant and you can
click this link and visit me there it's
always good to hear how you got on and
any feedback you might have now before
you begin why not head over to our
Discord server and meet the community
and let everybody know that you're
starting this course in the today I will
Channel and again this slide is a link
to that page on our Discord server
before we we dive into the concepts and
code let's get an intro to Lang chain
from the founding software engineer of
Lang chain Jacob
Lee Yes L chain is a framework that
helps developers build context aware
reasoning
applications Lang chain was born out of
the realization that the process of
developing sophisticated AI powered apps
could be significantly streamlined by
factoring out some common abstractions
while much of current AI app development
akes place in the realm of python
there's a clear need for better tooling
for the more webd focused JavaScript
Community too hence L chain comes in two
flavors and one of the aims of Lang
chain JS is to make large language
models and techniques around working
with them more accessible to this
broader audience in this course you'll
be learning how to use Lang chjs to
build your own apps it focuses in on
conversational retrieval over document
giving an llm access to the specific
information in that document so it can
answer questions and continue a logical
contextualized conversation on topics
Beyond its original training data along
the way you will use models prompts and
Alpha parsers some of the basic building
blocks of lank chain we'll create chains
of calls that enable us to connect up
the various stages in the process need
to get the desired output we'll be using
L chain with superbase and the open AI
API but one of the beauties of this
framework is that components are easily
swappable so you can work with a myriad
of databases Vector stores and llms
switch between them and find the one
which works for you best good luck and I
really hope you enjoy this course and
enjoy using L chain to spin up really
powerful AI web
apps of how this app is going to work in
this first section we need to work with
our data so this chatbot is going to be
knowledgeable about a specific Topic in
this case the scrimber platform so we're
going to start off with an information
source which holds the knowledge we want
the chatbot to have and we're going to
pass this document to a splitter and the
splitter is a lang chain tool which will
split the document into chunks and then
we're going to use an embeddings model
from open AI to create vectors from each
chunk and we're going to save those
chunks to our Vector store which in this
case is going to be a superbase vector
store when we get to this point the
vector store is established it's got all
of the knowledge we want it to have and
we won't need to repeat this process
unless we want to give it more knowledge
by adding some new data now if you don't
understand the justification for each
step or you're not really clear on
vectors and embeddings yet don't worry
we're going to go into a lot more detail
when we actually write the code this is
just an overview now once we've got the
vector store set up we need to create
the app to use it and the flow of that
app is going to look like this we start
off with a user which we've got
represented right here and that user
will input something probably a question
they have about scrimber and we're going
to do two things with that question
we're going to save it to a conversation
memory store which will hold the entire
conversation and we'll use an open AI
model to convert it to a standalone
question and that just means we're going
to reduce it to a very concise question
with no unnecessary words we'll then
take that Standalone question and we'll
use an open AI embeddings model to
create vectors from it we'll send those
vectors to our superbase Vector store
and we'll get back the chunk or chunk
with the nearest match therefore the
chunks that are most likely to contain
the answer to our question the last
stage is to use an open AI model to get
the final answer and to give it the best
chance of getting a good answer we're
going to give it three pieces of
information we're going to bring down
the nearest matches from the vector
store we'll give it the original user
input and we'll also give it the
conversation memory which will be the
entire conversation that has taken place
so far so that might be a very very long
conversation or this might be the first
question in the conversation now we're
going to take the response that we get
and we'll store it in the conversation
memory ready to continue the
conversation and also we'll give it back
to the user by rendering it to the Dom
now again this is a very high level
overview and it might well cause some
confusion for example what actually is a
standalone question and why are we using
it right here but then down here we're
using the original user input and not
the Standalone question but rather than
get caught up that right now and give
very theoretical answers what I want to
do is keep referring to this diagram as
we write the code and we're going to
tackle those questions as they come up
one by one so if this diagram looks
horribly confusing right now don't worry
at all we are going to take it step by
step okay in the next Grim let's go
right back to the beginning and think
about getting some data into our Vector
store but before we do that I'm going to
bring in a scrim from my colleague Gil
who's going to give you a detailed
overview of embedded ings so sit back
and take a few minutes to watch that
next powered search shapes many parts of
your daily lives every day you interact
with platforms sifting through massive
amounts of data from text and images to
audio and video think about Amazon
recommending products or search engines
refining your queries social media
platforms curate tailored content while
services like YouTube Netflix and
Spotify offer suggestions based on your
preferences now Advanced AIS despite
their capabilities don't truly
understand the real world as we do they
can't grasp the actual meaning or Nuance
of a video title song or news article so
how exactly do AIS and platforms like
Spotify Netflix and YouTube truly get us
how is it that they appear to understand
predict and respond to us as effectively
as if not better than people well the
magic behind this capability involves a
blend of algorithms AI models and huge
amounts of data but a larger part of the
answer involves embeddings you see when
you present a question to an AI it first
needs to translate it into a format it
can understand so you can think of
embeddings as the language that AI
understands the term embedding is a
mathematical concept that refers to
placing one object into a different
space think of it like taking a word or
sentence which is in a Content space and
transforming it into a different
representation like a set of numbers in
a vector space all while preserving its
original meaning and the relationships
between other words and phrases AI
systems process lots of data from user
inputs to information and databases at
the heart of this processing are
embeddings which are vectors
representing that data transforming
content like search queries photos songs
or videos into vectors gives machines
the power to effectively compare
categorize and understand the content in
a way that Almost Human so how is all of
this possible well it isn't exactly as
easy as just turning data into vectors
so before we go any deeper let's take a
closer look at what vectors are think of
a vector as a coordinate or point in
space and to keep things simple we'll
have a look at this 2D graph with an X
and Y AIS let's say that a word like cat
is translated into a vector like 4.5
12.2 which is this point this Vector
encapsulates the meaning and nuances of
the word cat in a way an AI model can
understand and then we have the word
feline represented by a nearby Vector of
4.7 12.6 so we'll place that point on
the graph now words that have similar
meanings are numerically similar and
tend to be closely positioned in the
vector space so this closeness implies
that cat and Feline have similar
meanings now let's say we have the word
or vectors for kitten which might also
be close to cat and Feline but maybe
slightly further apart due to its age
related Nuance now a dog dog is
different but still in the same general
domain of domesticated animals so the
word dog might be represented by a
vector that's not too distant but
clearly in a different region let's say
7.5 10.5 and even a phrase like Man's
Best Friend which is a colloquial term
for a dog could be represented by a
vector that's close to the vector for
dog on the other hand a word like
building is not related in meaning to
any of these so its Vector would be much
further apart let's say 15 .3
3.9 here's another example that
demonstrates how embeddings might
capture semantic meaning and
relationships between words let's say we
have the word King represented by the
vector 25 then man is the vector 13 and
woman is represented by the vector 14
now let's do some quick Vector
arithmetic we'll start with a vector for
King then subtract the vector for man to
remove the male context and add the
vector for woman to introduce new
context after performing this Vector
math our resulting Vector is
26 so we'll plot that point on the graph
and let's say there's another word in
our space queen represented by the
vector 2 6.2 right here well this Vector
is extremely close to the resulting
Vector so we might identify queen as the
most similar word based on that Vector
just as a trained AI model would now a
two-dimensional graph is a massive
simplification as real world embeddings
often exist in much higher dimensional
spaces sometimes spanning hundreds or
even thousands of dimensions for example
the actual Vector embedding for the word
Queen might have values across multiple
Dimensions each Dimension or number in
this Vector might capture a different
semantic or contextual aspect of the
word Queen for instance royalty
Cleopatra or even chess this is what
allows the AIS to recognize and
differentiate between these contexts
when the word is used in different
scenarios now imagine embedding hundreds
of thousands of words and phrases into
this high-dimensional space some words
will naturally gravitate closer to one
another due to their similarities
forming clusters While others are
further apart or sparsely distributed in
the space these relationships between
vectors are extremely useful think back
to spotify's method of embedding tracks
in a vector space tracks that are
positioned closely together are likely
to be played one after the other all
right so what else can we do with
embeddings and how are they used in the
real world well you can imagine how
embeddings have revolutionized our daily
experiences for example search engines
have evolved to understand the essence
of your queries and content moving
beyond mere keyword matching and
recommendation systems with the aid of
embedding suggest products movies or
songs that truly resonate with our
preferences and purchase history for
example Netflix uses them to create a
tailored and personalized platform to
maximize engagement and retention also
in the healthcare industry embeddings
are used to analyze medical images and
extract information doctors can use to
diagnose diseases and in the finance
World embeddings help with analyzing
financial data and making predictions
about stock prices or currency exchange
rates so every time you interact with an
AI chatbot every time an app recommends
something behind the scenes embeddings
are at work translating data into
meaning all right so how are these
embeddings actually created well let's
dive into that
next that Lang chain integrates with and
if you go to the Lang chain docs and
check out modules retrieval Vector
stores and Integrations you will see a
whole long list of them and by the way
this slide is a link through to that
page in the docs now for this project
we're going to use super base and
superbase is a really popular and very
userfriendly Vector store but one of the
beauties of Lang chain is that it's
actually really easy to swap out your
vector store so if you want to
experiment with various possible
Integrations that won't be too much
trouble at all now our first task is to
set up a superbase account so so head
over to superb.com and again this slide
is a link to superb.com and let's select
start your project and there you can
sign up with your email or GitHub and
once you've completed the sign up you'll
end up at the dashboard so let's go to
new project and we need to give the
project a name I'm going to call this
one scrim bot and we'll also need a
database password and I'm just going to
allow it to generate a random password
password for me and lastly I just need
to select my location I'm here in
Western Europe not that far from London
so that will do just fine then we can
scroll down to the bottom and just click
create new project now you'll wait a
while while it initializes a couple of
minutes at the most and eventually
you're going to end up here and that
shows us that we've got one database
successfully set up now if you click on
this tables icon on the left hand side
here in the table editor tab is where
you could manually set up a table but we
don't need to do any of that because
Lang chain is going to do it all for us
if we go back to the Lang chain docs to
the super base Integrations page and we
just scroll down we get this chunk of
code and we're going to run this in our
superbase database and it's going to do
everything that we need now I've just
pasted this code into scrimber just so
it's easier to look at and just to be
clear we're not running SQL or SQL right
here in scrimba we'll be running it in
super base and I'll show you how in just
a moment but I just wanted to put it
right here so we can have a look at it
in a bit more detail so what this code
does is it enables a PG Vector extension
in superbase it then creates our table
with everything that we need in that
table and it sets the embeddings to 1536
and that's an important number because
the open AI embeddings model use 1536
Dimensions it also gives us this match
documents function and it's this
function which actually does the job of
finding the the nearest match so later
we'll be using this function to take the
vectors from a question and find the
nearest vectors from the text chunks
because that will identify the text
chunks which are most likely to contain
the correct answer so all we need to do
with this code is copy it go back to
superbase and come into the SQL editor
tab which is this second one down and
paste it right in there now at the
moment it's just called Untitled query
which is not a great name so I'm just
going to change mine to match documents
because that's what this main function
in it is called now it tells us click
run to execute your query so we can do
that right here and there we are it says
success and if we go to the table editor
and we click on documents we can see
that we've got our empty table we've got
the ID the content the metadata and the
embedding I.E the vector and that is
what we asked for right here where we
said create table documents so that has
worked just fine we've got this warning
about allowing Anonymous access but
don't worry about that right now this is
going to be absolutely fine for
prototyping now if you'd like to take a
deeper dive into vectors and embeddings
and exactly what superbase is doing here
do check out this blog post that I've
linked to right here it's got quite a
lot of
information okay so now our database is
ready to go so in the next Grim let's
start getting some vectors into the
vector
store
next which is going to be the knowledge
for our chatbot and split it into chunks
and the idea is that each chunk will be
big enough to hold a piece of
information so what you want to avoid is
having something like this one chunk
where we say we update our course is and
a second chunk saying on a regular basis
that piece of information needs to be in
one chunk else it's pretty much useless
now a chunk will often not be that small
in fact lots of our chunks are going to
hold whole paragraphs so there'll be
something much more like that and it
doesn't matter at all if there's more
than one piece of information in a chunk
and in fact that's very likely going to
happen all we're trying to achieve here
is being able to give an AI Model A
smallest chunk of text from which it can
find the answer to a question what we
could do is just upload a massive
document with every request to say the
open AI API but that would be very very
expensive with tokens so what we're do
here is much more economical much more
performance and much more scalable okay
that's the theory and this is the actual
text that we're going to be using for
our chatbot it's about 3,000 words long
and I've checked and vetted all of the
information myself that's really
important if the information in the
document at the start is faulty you're
never going to make a good chatbot now
I'm using a text file here for
Simplicity but Lang chain has actually
got several tools for working with
different formats so you can click
through to this section in the docs and
it will show you options like passing
PDF or extracting just the text from
HTML to give you just two examples but
here we're going to keep it simple and
just use a text file so in index.js then
I've got this TR catch we're fetching in
scrimba
dasinfozentrum
knowledge source for our chatbot and now
we need to split it and we're going to
do that using a tool from Lang chain
which will do most of the work for us so
I've got the Lang chain dependency
already installed and in scrimber we do
that using a three dot menu that appears
when you hover over dependencies you
can't see it in the recording but when
you click on that three dot menu and
select ad dependency a dialog box
appears and I can type in Lang chain and
it does the rest for me outside of
scrimba of course you can use npm
install Lang chain okay now Lang chain
offers us a couple of tools to split
text there is the character text
splitter and the recursive character
text splitter I'm going to use the
latter which is just a little bit more
sophisticated but to be honest you can
use either and I didn't see a big
difference in performance between them
in this app so let's import the tool
from Lang chain and if you want the more
basic character text splitter it's just
going to look like that okay let's save
a new instance of this recursive
character text splitter to a const
splitter and then we'll save our output
we'll call splitter and use the create
documents method now we need to pass
create documents an array and inside the
array we can list out what we want to be
split we've only got one file text but
if we wanted to upload to a vector store
from multiple files we could list them
out in here okay let's just log out the
output and see what we get and I'll hit
save and then in the console we can just
see a promise and that's because this is
an async process so we need to await it
and there we are as soon as we do that
we see our chunks of text and I'm just
going to copy one of those chunks and
bring it over to Output MD so we can
have a look at it so it looks like this
we've got page content and that has got
the actual chunk of data now it's
actually much much long longer than that
the scrimba console truncates it heavily
and then we've also got the metadata the
metadata is quite interesting it gives
us the location of that text Chunk lines
1 to 14 so what we're actually looking
at if we go back to scrimba info. text
is right from the beginning from 1 down
to 14 so that is our text Chunk now we W
be using this location data in our app
but it is good to know for future
reference that if you need to refer to
where some information came from you
have got that information right there
provided to you by this text splitting
tool now this text splitter that we've
used the recursive character text
splitter has made some assumptions about
chunk size it actually defaults to a
th000 characters does chunk size matter
well yeah you bet it does larger chunks
get more context smaller chunks get more
granular semantic info if you go to
either Extreme Performance could suffer
and if chunks are really big sending
that off to the AI models will get
expensive now of course there's no best
way of splitting and you do have to
consider the text you're working with
I've experimented a bit and I want to go
for a chunk size of 500 not 1,000 so I'm
going to come in here with an object and
override the default
settings so I'll set my chunk size to
500 again we'll hit save and what you
can see is where before the first chunk
went from lines 1 to 4 14 now we're
going from lines 1 to 8 so the chunk is
a little bit smaller and I'm just going
to use Chrome Dev tools not scribus
console to get the text from the first
two
chunks okay so there we are we've got
the first text Chunk and the second text
Chunk right here and what you'll notice
is that these text chunks are actually
split quite nicely into paragraphs this
first one ends at a very natural point
and this second one does as well and
that is not an accident and you'll also
notice we've got some overlap here this
is a repetition of what we've got right
here and again that is not accidental so
if we just go back to this object and I
can come in here and show you a couple
more defaults firstly we have these
separators and these separators are an
array and they go in order so we've got
the double new line to break a paragraph
the single new line the space and then
no space so what this recursive
character text splitter does is actually
quite complex it uses those separators
to split text into chunks based on the
size but prioritizing keeping paragraphs
then sentences then words together
intact so that's why in these text
chunks we've got right here we've got
more than one piece of information but
that's absolutely fine because they're
both contained inside a chunk and they
both finish on a natural break and we've
got some overlap now we can also
override the overlap and it actually
defaults to 200 which is quite a lot so
I'm going to come in here and this is
called chunk overlap and I'm going to
set it to 50 so 10% of our chunk size
which is a good rule of thumb to start
with and you can always experiment now
you won't always see overlap and that's
because when the paragraphs fit neatly
into the chunks and the overlap size is
not big enough to include a whole
sentence then the overlap won't be
applied it will actually only be applied
if the chunk size does not end with one
of the first two separators so the
double new line or the single new line
so that is all a little bit confusing
and I wouldn't recommend that you worry
about it too much do play around with it
try different strategies also try the
more basic character text splitter and
just see which one gets you the best
performance with your chatbot and
remember you can always come back and
adjust it later if necessary now I
should just add that if you've got some
other separators in your document it's
quite popular to use say the double
hashtag you can also just add them to
this array it does accept custom
separators okay I haven't got any of
them in our document so I'm going to
delete that and the next thing to do
then is to take these chunks of text and
get them uploaded to the vector store so
let's look at that in the next
scrim to store and the first thing that
I'm going to do is come in here and save
our superbase URL and API key to consts
and we can get all of the information
that we need from the dashboard if you
come down here to settings and select
API here we have got the project URL and
the API key and I've saved mine in my
environment variables so I'm just going
to come in here and set up the
consts and of course you'll need to use
whatever you called your URL and API key
when you set up your M variable now I'm
also going to bring in the open aai API
key as we're going to need that in just
a
moment next I need to set up a superbase
client and we do that using the create
client method which we get from
superbase so before we can use that I
need to add the superbase dependency and
there we are the superbase dependency
has appeared and I'm just going to put
the the name of the dependency in a
comment just so you can see it a little
bit more clearly okay now we've got that
superbase dependency we need to import
the create client method from
it and now we can use create client to
set up a
client now let's use create client with
our URL and API key to set up a
superbase
client in the final stage of this we do
two things at once we're going to create
our embedded and we're going to upload
them to the vector store to do that we
need two tools from nchain the superbase
vector store and the open AI embeddings
class so let me just import them
quickly okay first we're going to use
the superbase vector store class so down
here I will say await because it does
work asynchronously
super base Vector store and we're going
to use its from documents method and we
need to give this method three pieces of
information the first one is the output
that we've got right here so remember
the output is the chunks of text that
we've
split next we need to tell it how to
create our embeddings and we're going to
do that with the open AI embeddings that
we've just imported so we'll set up a
new instance of that class and we just
need to pass it at open AI API key which
we've got right here now we could pass
that as a key value pair like this but
as the key and the value are actually
the same we don't need to do that we can
use the shorthand version Okay the third
piece of information is an object
holding our superbase
details so it needs our client and again
we don't need to write out the key value
pair we can just use the shorthand
version it also needs a table name and
if we go back to superbase we can just
see that when we go to the tables tab
our table name is just
documents and just before we run into an
error let's remember that this needs to
be a string okay let's hit save and see
if it works and actually we should have
logged something out there with a
success message but I totally forgot but
now we can go back to our superbase
dashboard and I'm just going to come up
here to the tables Tab and let's go to
documents and we can see it's worked we
have got our data we've got the ID the
content which is the text for each chunk
the metadata and the actual embedding
here are our vectors and remember this
field is huge we have got 1536
Dimensions here okay now we've got our
vectors in our Vector store we can start
work on the app that's going to allow us
to query this Vector store so when
you're ready for that let's
go
already have over on the right hand side
you can see that we've still got our
dependencies from Lang chain and
superbase now this event listener at the
top is listening out for user input so
it's basically picking up clicks on this
button when a user submits a question
we've also still got our API key here
that we're bringing in from our
environment variable and that just
leaves this function progress
conversation socalled because it
progresses the conversation onwards and
also does the heavy lifting of updating
the Dom so the user can actually see
what response they've got back from the
AI now it's all fairly straightforward
JavaScript but do feel free to pause and
take a look through and also do check
out the HTML and CSS if you want to
again it's fairly standard stuff okay so
that's the code we're starting with so
where do we go next with this project
well let's head back to the diagram and
see where we go first so we take the
users input we've got the event listener
listening out for that and then we do
two things we've got the conversation
memory right here and the Standalone
question right here I want to focus in
on the Standalone question first so
let's start by unraveling its Mysteries
and see what it actually is and why we
want it so we'll come on to that in the
next
scrim question and just to be clear
there are two things we need to do with
the users's input they're creating the
Standalone question and adding the
user's input to the conversation memory
now we're actually going to deal with
memory at the very end so let's just
ignore that for the time being and
concentrate in on the Standalone
question so what actually is a
standalone question well a standalone
question is just a question reduced to
the minimum number of words needed to
express the request for information okay
but why do we want one well we can't
control control what a user asks our
chatbot and actually a user could easily
ask a question in a way that's likely to
get a vague or even an inaccurate
response and we really want to avoid
that so imagine you have an online
clothes shop and a user asks something
like this I'm thinking of buying one of
your t-shirts but I need to know what
your returns policy is as some T-shirts
just don't fit me and I don't want to
waste money it's a perfectly reasonable
question but let's remember how chatbots
work we're trying to find the nearest
matching vectors and therefore the chunk
of text that will likely hold the answer
to our question we want to create an
embedding from this question and find
the nearest matching vector and
therefore the chunk of text that will
likely hold the answer to the question
in our Vector database but there's so
much going on with this question that
the vector for it will be polluted
remember a vector represents the
semantic meaning not the precise words
so what we want to do to maximize the
accuracy of our chatbot is just extract
the intended semantic meaning from this
question what we want to focus in on is
I need to know what your returns policy
is and we can reduce that to a
standalone question that will simply be
this what is your returns policy that is
what the user wants to know and so that
is what we need to search for in our
knowledge document so that will be our
first task and to do that we need to
take a look at how prompts work in Lang
chain and also how we send them off to
the llm the large language model so
let's do that in the next
scrim chain to set up a simple prompt
and just for demonstration purposes
we're going to move away from our main
project and imagine we're building an
app which generates a promotional tweet
for a given product we've got the Lang
chain dependency already installed right
here and of course we're bringing in the
open AI API key next we need to to
import two things from Lang chain first
the chat open aai class and we also need
the prompt template class so let's set
up our llm and save it to a const so
we'll take the chat open AI class and
pass in our API
key now we could instead pass in nothing
and if we do that Lang chain will check
process. mv. openai API key and use it
if it's available so we could actually
delete this line of code as well but to
be honest I think it's clear if we just
add it manually so I'm going to do it
that way and also if we wanted to
override any open AI defaults we could
do that right here in this object for
example we could change the temperature
setting so now this llm will use a
temperature of 0.5 but to be honest I
don't want that I'm just going to leave
everything at default for now okay now
let's create a template for our tweet
and I'm going to save it in a const
tweet
template and I'm just going to say
generate a promotional tweet for a
product from this product
description and we need to give it a
product description so I'm just going to
put the product description variable
inside curly
braces now as soon as you see the curly
braces you might think that this is a
standard JavaScript template literal
it's actually not there's no dollar sign
needed here this input variable will be
picked up by Lang chain and of course we
could have several input variables here
if we wanted to if this prompt was going
to be a little bit more complex we could
also have for example price and anything
else we needed but let's just keep this
really simple okay now we need to turn
this template into a prompt so I'm going
to set up a const for the
prompt and now we can use the prompt
template class and that comes with the
from template method and then we just
need to pass in our template and before
we go any further why don't we just log
out the Tweet prompt and see what we've
got I'll hit save and we we're getting
an error let's just check the console
and it says chat open AI cannot be
invoked without new okay that's a pretty
clear error we needed the new keyword
right here let's try that one more time
and there we are we've got our prompt
and just so we can look at it a little
bit more easily I'm just going to bring
it into a markdown file and format it
okay so we can see that we've got our
prompt right here just as we wrote it
and the interesting thing is that we've
got this input variables property and
that is holding product desk so that's
telling the prompt which inputs to
expect and this is an array so if we had
lots of input variables they would just
be listed out in this array and now that
the prompt is expecting them it's going
to throw an error if it doesn't get them
another interesting thing to notice here
that the template format is an F string
and an FST string is something which
comes from Python and it is the kind of
python equivalent to a template literal
okay so that is our prompt ready to go
so in the next Grim let's take a look at
how we can use it to generate some
content template is time to set up our
first chain in Lang chain I'll set up a
const tweet chain to hold it and what
this chain will consist of is our prompt
chained to our llm and to join the two
parts of the chain together we use the
pipe
method and I'm going to pass in the llm
so the pipe method is joining the two
aspects of the chain it takes the output
from the first which will be the prompt
and it passes it to the llm it's a
really simple chain with just one
connection again let's just log that out
and see what we
get and again I'm just going to paste
that into our markdown
file okay we've got quite a lot going on
here but I want to draw your attention
particularly to runnable sequence
because that is a theme that we're going
to be coming back to quite a bit in this
course but just by way of an intro what
we've got here is a runnable sequence
and we can see that this object right
here is called First and that is the
first element in our chain we've got our
prompt right here with our input
variables and then we've also got last
which is the last section of the chain
and here you can see that we have got
our open AI llm or large language model
now if this were a more complex chain
here in the middle we would see some
more steps but for now it's just enough
to know that this runnable sequence
exists okay so if we go back to index.js
what we need to do next then is invoke
this chain to start the sequence in
motion and we're going to do that with a
method called invoke so let's set up a
response and we need to await our tweet
chain because this is an asynchronous
process now let's call the invoke method
on the
chain and we'll just log out the
response now if we hit save right now
what do you think is going to happen
well we're getting an error down in the
console it says missing value for input
product desk well that figures because
look we're expecting an inut variable
right here product desk and we're not
actually introducing a product
description to the chain so what we need
to do then is pass in an object right
where we invoke the chain so you can
think of this as passing something in
right to the beginning of the chain and
what we need to pass in is a product
description so product desk will be our
key and then the value will be whichever
product we want a tweet for okay let's
save that again and down in the console
we have got our tweet and in fact we can
Zone in specifically on the Tweet by
saying response.
content and there we are we've got our
tweet it's even got some emoji and some
hashtags so this is working okay this
would be a great time just to pause make
sure you understand this code maybe
generate a couple of tweets perhaps make
this tweet template a little bit more
complex with multiple input variables
and then when you're ready we'll go back
to our main project where we need a
prompt and a model and that will give us
a great opportunity to have our first
challenge so when you're ready for that
just move
on prompt template and chat open AI
already imported we've also got our open
AI API key and the llm already set up so
here is your challenge I want you to
create a prompt to turn a user's
question into a standalone question and
I've just put a hint here the AI
understands the concept of a standalone
question you don't need to explain it
just ask for it then create a chain with
the prompt and the model and lastly
invoke the chain remembering to pass in
a question and for now we'll just log
out the response to check it's working
now just to be clear in this challenge
we are not going to be wiring this up to
the chat interface yet if we were going
to do that we would have to actually
come down here into this progress
conversation function and update some of
the logic in here it's a little bit of
unnecessary complication at this point
we will be coming on to that later also
I've given you the four consts that
you're actually going to need to
complete this Challenge and we're just
logging out the response right here I've
also given you some hints above each
const and I've done that because there
is quite a lot of new syntax here and of
course you are welcome to go back to
that scrim to check the syntax if you
need to but hopefully with these hints
that might not be necessary now when you
do this just remember that the question
you pass in should be quite a long-
winded question because the idea is to
reduce that question down to just the
bare minimum so you want to make that a
long question with some unnecessary
words it's only then that we'll be able
to see that it works okay pause now take
all the time you need and I'll see you
back here in just a
moment okay okay so hopefully that went
just fine so we'll start off with the
Standalone question template this is
going to be a string and we're just
going to ask for what we want so I'm
going to say given a question convert it
to a standalone
question and then I'm going to say
question colon and here I'll use the
curly braces and we'll introduce the
input variable which is question now
I'll invite the model to provide us with
the Standalone question by saying
Standalone question and just finishing
on a colon so that's like an invitation
to complete right now we need the prompt
so let's set Standalone question prompt
equals to prompt template and we'll use
the pr template method and pass in
Standalone question template then we'll
set up the chain so we'll take the
prompt that we've just created and we're
going to link up the chain with the pipe
method and we're piping the llm and
remember we've got the llm already set
up right here okay to check it's working
we need to invoke it and pass in a
question so we'll take that chain and
this is an async process so we'll await
the Standalone question chain call the
invoke method and we'll pass in an
object we've got the input variable that
the prompt is expecting right here it's
question and for our question I'm going
to go for something quite
longwinded I've asked what are the
technical requirements for running
scrimba I only have a very old laptop
which is not that powerful okay we're
logging out the response so let's hit
save and see what we get down in the
console and there we are can a very old
laptop meet the technical requirements
for running scrimber it's reduced that
question down to a standalone question
it's just asking for the precise
information and it's removed unnecessary
words okay that is the first part done
so now is a really good time to take a
break and relax especially if you've
been working at this for a while and
when you're ready to go on we're going
to look at how we can take our
Standalone question to get chunks of
matching text from the vector store but
there is quite a lot to do that there
are several steps in that process and
some preparation so for now take a
moment to chill and come back when
you're
ready and see where we are and we are
right here so we've taken the users's
input and we've created this Standalone
question from it and the next step will
be to create embeddings from that
Standalone question and then take that
to the vector store to find the closest
match so if we have a standalone
question like what is a scrim we'll use
the embeddings model to create our
vector and then in the vector store we
will search through all of the vectors
we'll find the closest match and we'll
take that chunk of text now this diagram
is a little bit of a simplification we
might not just take one chunk of text we
might take two three even 10 chunks of
text and a bit later on we'll look at
how we can exert control over how many
chunks we retrieve from the vector store
okay before we can do any of that we
need some basic setup so I've bought in
a few Imports here which we've seen
before we've got the superbase vector
store class I've also bought in the open
AI embeddings from Lang chain and create
client both of which we used before when
uploading to the vector store so those
are all of the Imports we need for now
and then down here I've set up a new
instance of embeddings I've passed in
the open a API key do remember that if
you don't pass anything in Lang Chain by
default will look for process. mv.
openai API key in this format and do it
for you I'm going to pass it in here
manually just for clarity okay we've
also got our superbase API key and the
superbase URL and we've used that to set
up the client and again that is
identical code to when we were uploading
to the data store okay now things get a
bit different to what we did before
let's start a new instance of the
superbase vector store in a const and
and we're going to pass it our
embeddings
model and we'll also pass it a
configuration object in this
configuration object we only really need
to pass it the client but again just for
clarity I'm also going to pass it the
table
name and our table name in superbase was
documents we can see that one right here
in the superbase dashboard and I'm also
going to give it the query name and
again if we look at the superbase
dashboard we've got this query match
documents which we named after this
function match documents so let's pass
that in right here so these two are both
defaults but I think it's a good idea to
put them in here right now because if in
the future you're working with a more
advanced use case perhaps you've got
more than one table or more than one
query name it's important that you know
that this is where you can configure
your vector store okay now this is quite
different to what we were doing when we
were uploading to the vector store we
actually want to retrieve something and
without Lang chain we would have to
actually write a ton of code to do that
but now all we're going to do is create
a new const and I'm going to call it
Retriever and I'm going to set it equals
to our Vector
store and I'm going to call the as
retriever method on it and that is all
we need to do this as retriever method
knows to go to the vector store and
instead of inserting more data to use
the matching documents function that we
added here to find the nearest matches
so that makes it nice and easy and if
you'll remember this match documents
query came straight from the Lang chain
docks so all of that provided by Lang
chain just makes life really easy okay
this retriever is now finished and that
means it can now be added as an element
in a lang chain chain so let's do that
next we're just going to come in here
down to our chain which we've got right
here and we're just going to pipe the
retriever on the
end so what should now happen is that we
invoke the chain and we pass in this
question at the top of the chain the
Standalone question prompt creates its
own prompt from that question it's piped
to the llm to get the Standalone
question and that should now be piped to
the retriever to retrieve the nearest
chunks from the vector store well we're
logging out the response let's hit save
and see what happens and if we open up
the console we're getting an error and
it's one of those kind of vague errors
e. replace is not a function so I think
what we should do next is isolate our
Retriever and see if it's working so I'm
actually going to delete this pipe that
we put on the end of this chain and I'm
going to set up a second response right
here and this is just a test so I'm just
going to call it response two and what
we're going to await here is our
retriever we'll call the invoke method
and we'll just pass in a standalone
question and I'm going to follow on from
this question here and just say will
scrimber work on an old
laptop okay let's just log out response
2 and see what we get and look we are
getting some chunks and we can see that
we've actually got four chunks and the
first one starts what are the technical
requirements so that is looking good for
an answer to this question so I'm
thinking that our retriever is working
just fine so why is it not working in
this chain well I think if we log out
the original response as well we might
see an answer to that question so let's
run this again and now we've got quite a
lot of data in our console too much to
see easily so I'm just going to paste it
into a markdown file okay so what we can
see is that where we were logging out
the original response we have got this
object right here and we've got the
Standalone question what are the minimum
technical requirements for running
scrimba can I use it on an old less
powerful laptop so that was the
Standalone question here we've got our
chunks and we've got four of them and
that's great so what exactly is the
problem if you want just pause for a
moment and see if you can figure it
out okay so maybe youve figured out that
if we have a look at the chain what
we're actually doing when we pass things
along the chain is passing them along in
their expected data type so we invoke
this chain with this string and the
Standalone question prompt is expecting
a string and the llm is expecting the
output of the Standalone question prompt
it knows what format that's coming in
but when we try to pipe the retriever on
the end what we're doing is we're
passing along this object but what we've
just seen from our experiment
is that the retriever works with a
string so the only problem here is that
we need to be passing along just the
string from this response now we could
do that with DOT or bracket notation but
Lang chain actually gives us a better
way of doing it and it introduces us to
the concept of an output passer and that
is something that you should know about
so let's look at that
next so Lang chain offers various output
passes to suit some specific situations
so for example you might need to Output
in Json or you might even need binary
data we're not doing anything so complex
here but we can use the most simple
output passer which is the string output
passer and as the name suggests it's
going to pass the output as a string so
if we go back to our code I've put this
chain back to how it was we're piping in
the retriever at the end and we're just
logging out the response now we already
know that that doesn't work we're
getting this error so now let's import
the string output
passer and all I need to do is add a new
instance of the string output passer to
the chain and it's going to come right
in here so we're taking what we get back
from the llm and that is what we want to
pass as string so let's come in here and
we're going to pipe in the string output
passer and the string output passer is a
class and in here I just want a new
instance of it it and let's invoke that
and when we hit save and I open up the
console there we are it is working we
have chained everything together and now
we are getting the four chunks back from
the vector store and just to see the
string output pass in action let's
quickly delete the retriever so I'll
just delete this off the end now when I
hit save the output from the llm is just
a string before without the output
passer we were getting an object okay
let's just put all of that back so that
is pretty cool we're definitely making
progress however you might be looking at
this and thinking we've got pipe and
pipe and pipe how many pipes are there
going to be in this chain and also this
chain is called Standalone question
chain but we've just added the retriever
on the end and that is a little bit
strange so why don't we just come in
here right now and do a mini refactor
and I'm just going to call this chain
chain and of course we need to update
that where we invoke it shortly we'll be
breaking this chain up and doing a
bigger refactor but first I want to show
you the limits of what we can do with
just the pipe method so next let's think
about using what we've got down in the
console to try to formulate an answer to
our question now I think we going to run
into not one but two problems so let's
go and check that
out feeling it was starting to get kind
of messy and we've got another prompt to
add so to tidy things up a bit I've
taken all of the retriever code and
given it its own file here inside this
utils folder I'm just exporting it and
then importing it back into index JS
right here the retriever is pretty
stable now we will do a tiny bit more
with it later but it's good to tuck it
out of the way and we'll do that as we
go along just to keep things here in
index.js manageable okay let's go back
to the app so we've got this chain down
here which we're invoking with this
question and the question becomes a
standalone question which we're using to
get relevant chunks of data from the
vector store so if we have a look at our
flow diagram we've done all of this
we're right here we're finding the
nearest match from the vector store and
what we want to do next is create a
prompt to get us the answer now we're
going to do that using three pieces of
information we need the nearest match
from the vector store we need the user
input which we're getting right here
that's not the Standalone question
that's the original question that the
user asked and we also need the
conversation which will later be stored
in memory now we're not doing that until
the end so I'm going to leave the
conversation crossed out for now now it
might cause you a bit of confusion that
we're creating a standalone question
here but we're not actually using it to
get the answer so just to explain the
role of the Standalone question is to
get the most relevant information from
the vector store the the original
question might well contain more data
which the llm can actually use to
generate a more relevant conversational
answer but we wouldn't want to use that
data to find matches in the vector store
let me just show you what I mean with a
little diagram so imagine a user comes
to our chatbot and they say I'm a
complete beginner and really nervous is
scrimba for me well we reduce that to a
standalone question is scrimba suitable
for beginners now if we use that
question to generate our final answer
our final answer would look something
like this yes scrimba is suitable for
beginners and that's a perfectly correct
reasonable answer and it will leave the
user feeling I think fairly neutral now
if we use this original question when we
form the final answer we can actually
use the extra information that we didn't
use when we were going to the vector
store so that means we'll be able to
form a more conversational response yes
scrim is perfect for you we're a
friendly community so don't be nervous
and that will actually give the end user
a much more positive feeling from the
chatbot okay so that's why we're using
the original question in our answer
template so now it's time for a
challenge and here it is I want you to
create a template and prompt to get an
answer to the user's original question
remember to include the original
question and the text chunks we got back
from the vector store as input variables
and you can call those input variables
question and context and I've just put
this warning here that if you go ahead
and add this to the chain this is where
you're going to find the limitations of
chaining pipe methods together so don't
be surprised when you get an error you
might already see where the error is
coming from and in fact there's going to
be more than one problem to solve here
and it will take us several scrims so
really just take this challenge as
prompt template practice and I've put
here a wish list of what we want this
chatbot to be able to do so you can and
think about that as you're writing your
prompt okay pause now get this challenge
sorted and we'll have a look together in
just a
minute okay so hopefully you managed to
do that just fine I'm going to come in
here then and create an answer
template and this is the text I've
written you are a helpful and
enthusiastic support bot who can answer
a given question about scrimber based on
the context Prov divided try to find the
answer in the context so I've put that
in there just to emphasize that the
context is the knowledge that we want
the chatbot to use if you really don't
know the answer say I'm sorry I don't
know the answer to that and direct the
questioner to email help at sca.com
don't try to make up an answer and
always speak as if you were chatting to
a friend so so hopefully we'll get a
nice friendly engaging response from the
chatbot now we just need to add in the
input variables so we've got context and
remember that will be the chunks we got
back from the vector store and we've got
question and then I'll finish the prompt
with an invitation to
create okay now we need to use this
template in a
prompt and let's come down here and
we'll add it to the chain so we can just
pipe it right on the end and is this
going to work well no I've already given
you a spoiler this is going to cause us
an error and the error we're getting is
missing Val for input context so that's
pretty understandable we're not passing
in context in the format it's expecting
so what we need to do at this point is
rewind and start sorting out the data we
get back from the retriever it's a
little bit of a process but let's start
that in the next
scrim the output from the retriever is
this array of objects with metadata and
all we want is the text and we're not
trying to get that text into any special
format we just want a string so what we
can do is create a function to extract
the text join it into a string and we
can just add that function to the chain
so basically what we want this function
to do is map over this array get the
text from page content and join it into
a string so I'm going to call this
function combine
[Music]
documents and it can take in docs as a
parameter and that will be what we get
back from the Retriever and now we just
need to return the docs having mapped
over them and returned the page content
as we can see down in the console it's
the page content that we're interested
in and we need to join them together so
let's use the join method and we'll take
a double new line As the
separator let's see if that works so I'm
just going to add this function onto the
chain and now let's open up the console
at the moment we've got the array of
objects and when we hit save we get back
one one big string so that is working
that's really good let's try chaining on
then the answer prompt that we've got
right here and I'll hit save and we get
an error we're still missing the value
for the input context and I did warn you
there are multiple problems here so now
what we see are the limitations of this
pipe method we can give the answer
prompt a string but we don't have an
easy way to give it the object it wants
remember it wants both context and
question but luckily we have got another
way to make Chains It's an alternative
syntax called the runnable sequence we
did touch on it earlier and it gives us
more options now it's quite a big topic
we're going to take several scrims to go
over it but before we dive into that it
might be a good time to take a break if
you've been doing this for a while but
just before we finish in my effort to
keep this code base a little bit tidy
I'm just going to take this function
right here and move it into the utils
folder right when you're ready and
rested let's move on
I've got a feature from a language app
which is going to take in a sentence and
we've got one here I Don't Like Mondays
and it's going to do three things now
you'll notice I've marked some errors in
this sentence we've got a lowercase
first letter we're missing an apostrophe
in don't we've got a D on the end of
liked which makes no grammatical sense
and we're missing the uppercase first
letter Mondays now the first llm call is
going to solve the punctuation errors so
we'll get uppercase I apostrophe and
uppercase M we've still got the
grammatical error but that's dealt with
by the second llm call now the sentence
is correct and we'll use the third llm
call to translate that sentence to a
given language in this case French now
if that sounds a little contrived to you
well it probably is I was just looking
for a not too complex way of
demonstrating a few things with runnable
sequence so so just bear with me now
we've already got the first two prompts
here so we've got the punctuation prompt
and the grammar prompt and then we're
invoking the chain but at the moment the
chain doesn't
exist so let's build it using a runnable
sequence and we're going to start that
off by importing the runnable
sequence now let's come down here and
set up the chain so we'll say runnable
sequence which comes with a from method
and we pass in an array
and in this array we can start building
the chain so we'll start with the
punctuation prompt and let's just open
up the console let's just hit save and
see if that works and it actually fails
and that's happening because we've only
got one thing in the runnable sequence a
runnable sequence needs at least two
elements in the chain so let's add in
the llm and I'll hit save and this time
it looks like it's working we've got
down in the console I Don't Like Mondays
and as you can can see the punctuation
has been corrected the grammar mistake
liked with a d on the end is still there
okay next let's add the string output
passer and again I'll hit save and there
we are we're getting our string so this
is looking like a nice neat way to do
chains let's just add in the grammar
prompt we'll hit save oh and that one
fails and again we've hit the problem
that the template in grammar point is
expecting an input variable punctuated
sentence so let's just rewind now these
three elements in the chain work because
what they pass along is in the format
expected by the next element in the
chain now one thing that's really cool
with runnable sequence is that you can
put an arrow function in the chain and
log out exactly what's happening at that
point in the chain to see what's going
on so let's try that now so preve result
is a parameter in an arrow function and
I can call it whatever I want but preve
result seems like a good idea as we're
seeing the result of the previous action
so let's hit save and we're going to get
an error because we've broken the chain
but we will see what we're logging out
we've got the sentence property holding
I Don't Like Mondays and the language of
French and that is just logging out the
result of our invocation that we can see
right here so what I want to do next is
move this line of code down the chain
let's hit save again and we see the
punctuation prompt let's move it down
one more step
and now we see the result of the llm and
move it down to the end of the chain and
we see the result of the string output
passer and this is of course where we
hit a problem because the string output
passer is giving us a string and the
grammar prompt which is what comes next
in the chain is hoping for an object
which looks like
this punctuated sentence which is the
input variable and then a string with
whatever we got back from the string
output passer in here so we could
actually do that we could come in here
and build the object so we've got the
key punctuated uncore sentence and now
for the value we can just take pretty
much what we've got here although of
course we're going to delete the
console.log so we just return the
previous result and look at that it
works we're not actually seeing the
final result yet but that's just because
we need to chain in the llm and the
string output passer let's hit save
again and there we are now we've got our
Center it is completely correct there's
no grammatical errors and no punctuation
errors so this has worked but I don't
think it's very elegant and I don't
think it's very intuitive so in the next
Grim let's refactor this and we're going
to find a neater way of doing it but let
me just warn you before we finish this
trick with the arrow function in a
runnable sequence is actually very very
useful in some situations and we are
going to be using it in a challenge just
a little bit later so don't forget
it working but it's not the most elegant
so let's refactor now one option is to
go for a runnable sequence in a runnable
sequence so I'll come right in here
delete this and create a new runnable
sequence right here and we do that in
exactly the same way with the from
method and now I just need to list these
three inside that runnable sequence and
of course delete them from here and
let's just tidy up the formatting and
actually that line of code is so long
it's never going to look too good let's
just hit save and see what
happens so it does work it works
perfectly well but likewise I think this
is rather awkward so what I want to do
is actually extract this chain so I'll
create a const punctuation chain and
that is going to hold this runnable
sequence and now we can have whatever
this chain returns be the value of this
key value pair let's just bring this
back onto one line okay let's give it a
try and that works and by the way this
could be a runable sequence or it could
be a pipe chain it actually just doesn't
matter at all you might find for these
chains which are just a prompt an llm
and an output passer that using the pipe
method is just as good it makes the code
slightly sh water and it's a matter of
personal taste as to which one is easier
to read now I'm going to leave this as a
runnable sequence and I've just realized
I've got an unnecessary trailing comma
right there now I think this is going to
look neater still if we also extract the
grammar
chain and I'll just hit save and there
we are that works just as well Okay so
we've got the runnable sequence working
but we need to remember the last part of
our app which is a transl ation and
where we invoke this chain we are
passing in a language French and we're
not actually using that as yet in any of
our templates but when it comes to
having the translation template we are
going to need it so I'm thinking I'll
just come in here right now and I will
add in that translation template and
there we are we've got a translation
template and a prompt which comes from
it so what we'll be needing to do next
is potentially give it its own
chain and of course we need to add the
translation chain to the main chain now
do you think this is going to work well
of course it's not we've been here
before we're missing the input variable
for language and that figures because
we're not actually doing anything with
language we're invoking it here but we
haven't bought it into this chain and we
certainly haven't passed it down the
chain now strange as it may seem taking
this original input and passing it down
the chain is not a trivial thing to do
and Lang chain actually give us a
special tool to do just that so let's
check that out in the next
scrim slightly strange app we've added
the translation chain so we should be
able to get this translation of our
original sentence now it's not working
and we know why it doesn't have access
to the input variables it wants it wants
the language and grammatically correct
sentence input variables now the
grammatically correct sentence input
variable should be coming straight from
the grammar chain so we should be able
to break this one into an object and add
that really easily but what about this
language input variable we know it's
coming in here where we invoke the chain
but to pass it down through the chain we
actually need to use a special tool and
that special tool is called a runnable
pass through and we're going to import
it from from exactly the same place that
we get the runnable sequence so we can
just add it in right here okay so we use
it like this let's come to the first
element in the chain and we've got this
object and I'm just going to bring it
down onto two lines and now I'll add a
new key value pair and the key is going
to be original input and the value is
going to be a new instance of runnable
pass through now let's come in here to
this second object and again I'm going
to bring it onto multiple lines and here
I'm going to add a property original
input and for the value we're going to
use an arrow function just to log out
what the original input is and just
before we save that I'm just going to
comment out this line and now we won't
get confused by what we see in the
console and we're seeing out errors but
interestingly we're also logging out the
original input and we can see what
original input is in that object it's
the sentence I don't liked Mondays with
no punctuation or grammar and the
language French so it's actually this
object here that we passed in when we're
invoking the chain so what we can do now
then is destructure original input and
now we're destructuring we need to use
parentheses and then we should be able
to access the language just with
notation let's it save and see if that
works and it does work we're getting the
language French so let's just delete the
console.log and will just return the
language and of course we need to update
the key here to language because that is
the input variable that we're expecting
in this template and let's hit save and
see if it's worked oh and I think I
forgot to reinstate this line which
means we'll be waiting a long time let's
try that again and it does work we are
logging out our French sentence so we've
successfully removed all of the errors
and translated it into French and the
really important thing here is that
we've managed to pass an original input
right down through the chain so we can
get access to language in the final
element of the chain now just before we
move on I want to say a quick word about
formatting it might well be that if you
do use a runnable sequence here you
think it looks better if we bring down
the elements in these arrays onto their
own
lines and for me I think that probably
does look a bit
neater but that is a matter of personal
taste now have a good look at what we've
done here because everything that we've
done here is aping something that we
need to do in our app so when we go back
to the app I'm going to give you a big
Challenge and when you've completed that
challenge the app should be
fundamentally working bar one or two
Loose Ends so have a good look at this
code make sure you understand everything
and then when you're ready move
on
we have studied everything we need to
know to get this app to some kind of
minimum viable product what I mean by
that is by the end of the challenge we
should be able to see an answer to this
question down in the console and after
I've shown you my solution we're going
to wire up all of the Dom elements and
then we've just got a few final features
to add now I've imported the runnable
pass through and the runnable sequence
for you so you don't need to do that and
let's just quickly check out the flow
diagram to remind us where we are so
we've basically done all of this and now
we're going to be getting the answer
using the nearest match and the user
input we haven't wired up the
conversation yet we're doing that last
so I'm going to leave that crossed out
you don't need to worry about it so your
challenge is this I want you to set up a
runnable sequence so the Standalone
question prompt passes the Standalone
question to the Retriever and the
retriever passes the combined docs as
context to the answer prompt remember
the answer prompt should also have
access to the original question when you
finish the challenge you should see a
conversational answer to our question in
the console now I think the neatest way
to do this is to create three chains one
for each section so there'll be a
standalone question chain a retriever
chain and an answer chain and then you
can bring them together in a runnable
sequence but that said you might choose
to do it a bit differently now I'm going
to give you a choice here if you're up
for a challenge you can go ahead and get
to work but if you'd like a bit more
guidance I've got a file up here called
hints. MD and in here I've listed out
the steps that I would take to get this
working so you can refer to that if you
need to whether you look at that file or
not definitely feel free to go back to
the previous scrims to check out the
syntax as you do this and take as long
as you need this can be pretty confusing
at first but it really pays dividends to
figure this out yourself either with or
without the extra help in this file
rather than just watching my solution so
really give this Your Best Shot pause
now get to work on this and then move on
to the next Grim when you're ready to
see my way of doing it and it's probably
worth opening the next Grim in a new tab
so you can keep your solution to hand
for comparison
purposes and massive congratulations if
you did a few tricky bits to remember
there now I'll show you how I did it and
remember my way isn't the one true way
if you got it working your way might be
just as good or even better than mine so
I'm going to come in here and set up
three
chains the Standalone question chain the
retriever chain and the answer chain and
then this here we will reuse as the main
chain where we bring everything together
on this first chain I'm just going to
use the pipe method and I'm going to
chain together the Standalone question
prompt the llm and the string output
[Music]
passer now you could do this here with a
runnable sequence it's totally up to you
I've gone for the pipe method on these
basic chains because it just keeps the
code a little bit shorter now we could
also bring these pipes onto new lines
and that might make things a little bit
neater still okay I want to add this
first chain to our main chain so I'm
just going to delete all of the code
that we've got here and then the main
chain is going to be a runnable
sequence and then we'll pass in the
Standalone question chain now let's just
think for a second this chain will give
us two things it will give us the
Standalone question and the original
question that we'll need in the answer
prompt so let's create an object and
we'll have the Standalone question and
the value there will be whatever's
provided by the Standalone question
chain and we can have another property
which is the original input and that
will be a new instance of the the
runnable pass through okay and onto the
retriever chain and here we faced a bit
of a gotcha the retriever chain isn't
expecting an input variable but it needs
the string we get from the Standalone
question prompt so let's get at that
using an arrow function and that means
that this chain will need to be a
runnable
sequence so the first thing in this
chain will be the arrow function that
gets us the Standalone
question so we'll take preve result as
the parameter and we'll return pre
result. Standalone
question next in the chain we need the
retriever itself and finally we want to
extract the text from the array of
objects we got back from the Retriever
and we do that with the combined
documents function so in this chain
we're taking the previous result and
we're extracting the Standalone question
from it that's going to give us the
string which we pass to the retriever
the retriever finds the nearest matches
and brings them back to us as an array
of objects and the combined documents
function extracts just the text from
that array of objects and joins it into
a string okay let's add the retriever
chain to our main
chain and what the retriever chain needs
to pass on is the context because that
is what the answer template is expecting
as well as the original question so for
the context that's coming here with the
key as context the value is the
retriever chain and then for the
original question here we're going to
take the original input that we've
passed through with this runnable pass
through and extract the question from
it and now we just need to deal with the
answer chain and the answer chain is
going to be much like the Standalone
question chain so we'll set that equals
to the answer prompt and we'll pipe it
into the
llm and likewise we need a new instance
of the string output passer
okay that is the last link in the chain
so let's just add it on here in the main
chain and now I'm going to hit save and
let's see if we get an answer and look
we do it says scrimba is designed to be
lightweight and can be used on low speec
PCS so your old laptop should work just
fine so what we're getting there is an
answer to this question and that is
really really good that is exactly what
we want and the answer we're getting is
accurate it's from information that we
gave it in our original document and has
been turned into a conversational answer
by the llm so again congratulations if
you got it to this point now the end is
almost in sight in the next scrim I'm
going to wire up the UI that's pure
JavaScript there's no AI involved in
that if you fancy it as a challenge go
ahead and do it most of the code is done
for you if not just feel free to sit
back and watch on this
one
haven't really touched we've got this
event listener which is listening out
for a submit event which will fire when
this button is clicked and that's going
to call this progress conversation
function now if we come right down to
the bottom we can check out that
function and all we need to do to get
this working is to take this chain
invocation right here cut it and paste
it in here now I'm going to delete
delete the console.log we don't need
that and also we want to get rid of this
hardwired question and we're going to
invoke with whatever the user has
inputed and we've got that stored in
this Con right here question which is
coming from user input. value and that
is just being collected from this input
on submit and that is all we need to do
let's hit save and now I'm going to ask
it a question and I'm going to ask it
how long it will take to get a code
review for a solo project oh and we're
getting an error and it's saying result
is not defined and I think what I've
done here is I've called this one
response and this one down here result
well it doesn't really matter how we
changed this let's change this one to
response and I'll ask it the same
question and there we are we get a great
answer and that answer has come right
from the document that we gave it at the
beginning so that is really really good
now I'm going to ask it if it knows
about me Tom Chan is a scriber teacher
that's reassuring it knows that now
let's start again and I want to do an
experiment I'm going to introduce myself
and of course it doesn't know I'm a
scrimer teacher we've just refreshed it
doesn't know anything about me and in
fact I might just make up a
name so I've introduced myself and asked
what is scrimber and there we are we get
a great answer it gives us a lot of
detail greets me by my name so it's
being really conversational now I want
to ask it what is my name
and of course it doesn't know and the
good thing is it's advising us to email
help sca.com so it's got that straight
from our prompt I think that was right
there in the answer prompt here we are
email help.com if you don't know the
answer so that's working really well now
the fact that it doesn't know my name
when I gave it my name right here and
it's repeated it once tells us what we
already knew which is that this chatbot
has no memory so the last thing that we
need to do then is add some memory to
this app and we've got all of this left
on our flow diagram plenty of arrows
going on so it looks really complicated
but actually there's not much more to do
but we'll come on to that in the next
scrim some memory now there's two parts
to this there's some JavaScript to set
up and then we'll need to wire the
conversation memory into the chain so
that the answer prompt has got access to
it now I'm going to cover the JavaScript
setup in this scrim and you're going to
have the job of wiring it into the chain
in a challenge in the next scrim so
firstly I want to create a const to hold
the memory and this memory is going to
be an array and I'm just going to call
it conversation history so we'll come
outside of the progress conversation
function and this is where I'll set it
up and I think I'll abbreviate it to com
history now let's add to the
conversation history every time a user
submits a question and every time we get
a response back from the chain so we'll
come down here and we can say conf. push
and we'll push the question and the
response okay that deals with a couple
of arrows on this flow diagram so the
user input is now saved to the
conversation history and the answer we
get back from the chain is also added to
the conversation history but at the
moment all we're going to have stored in
this array is a bunch of strings which
is fine but it's going to help the AI
understand this better if it's clear
which strings come from humans and which
come from AI so I'm going to write a
function just to add a human or AI label
to each string and then we're going to
join them together into one big string
which we can use in our chain now again
in the interest of keeping index.js as
clean and clear as we possibly can I'm
going to create this function in utils
so we'll say function format com history
and it will take in an array of messages
and then it's going to map over those
messages now the Callback will have each
message as a parameter and also the
index and we're just going to work out
whether it's a human or AI message by
doing some basic maths on the
index so what we're assuming here is
that the human speaks first so the
zeroth message will be a human and all
of the odd number numbers will be Ai and
all of the even numbers will be human
now we just want to join them together
into one string and let's just join them
on a new line character now when we call
the function on the conversation history
what it would do is it will take the
array of strings and convert it to this
so there's one long string but it's
really clear what the human said and
what the AI said okay let's delete this
and we'll export this function and
import it back back into
index.js right so the setup is done and
in the next Grim you can wire this into
the
chain let's wire up this memory now at
the moment on this diagram we need the
conversation history right here where we
get the final answer to our question but
I think it might help performance if we
have access to the conversation history
where we're creating ating the
Standalone question it might just help
it create a better Standalone question
in some Edge situations so I'm going to
add another arrow to this diagram now we
want our conversation history from our
memory store in two places the
Standalone question and the answer chain
at the very end and that means it's time
for a super challenge or a mediumsized
super challenge it's not quite as big as
the previous super challenge but there
is quite a lot to do so I want you to
pass history into the chain as comore
history at the point where we invoke it
and I've just put remember to make use
of our format com history
function now if we just go back to where
we invoke the chain this is where you
can pass in comcore history and I've
just put the underscore in just to keep
up with the same format that we've used
throughout once you've passed that in
and you've used the format com history
function The Next Step will be to come
to the Standalone question template and
make use of con history in that template
and all I mean by that is come here into
the template we're going to add con
history as an input variable somewhere
and just update the instruction so it
knows it can use the conversation
history as a resource as well when
you've done that we need to come to the
answer chain and we need to make sure it
has access to com history so again down
in the chain you're going to need to do
something around here once you've done
that and the answer chain has got access
to com history again you need to come to
the answer template and use an input
variable to add com history somewhere in
here and instruct it on how to use it
now if I were you I would just use
wording in here that makes it clear that
it can use the conversation history to
help it find the best answer but that
the source of knowledge Remains the
context so I'll leave it up to you to
think of some work wording there and
then you can see what I did and of
course in the real world you'd have to
play around with this prompt template
and just do some experimentation until
you get results that you're happy with
okay once you've done that we should be
done so you can test it by giving the
chatbot some information and checking in
the next question to see if it remembers
it so a really easy way of doing that is
exactly what I did before tell it your
name and see if it remembers your name
okay quite a lot to do there so pause
now give this your best shot and we'll
have a look at it together together in
just a
moment okay hopefully you managed to do
that just fine so let's come down to
where we invoke the chain and I've
already added the comore history
property and the value there will be con
history however before we send that off
we want to format it so let's take our
function format com history and we'll
just pass in com history
okay let's go back to the challenge so
we've got com history in the chain and
we've formatted it let's go to the
Standalone question template to make use
of com history right there and I'm going
to convert this to back ticks and I'm
just doing that because like with the
answer template we're going to end up
with a list of input variables so it's
just a bit neater when it's back ticks
and we can spread it out onto multiple
lines now I'm going to update the text
right here so I've just said given some
conversation history if any and a
question convert the question to a
standalone question and then here we've
got our requests for input and then here
I'm going to bring things down onto a
new line and we'll add the conversation
history input
variable so now we need to make sure the
answer chain has access to com history
and we need to edit the answer template
to make use of it well that's actually
two things in one let's come down to the
chain and then right here we're using
this runnable pass through to get access
to the original question now we can do
exactly the same thing with com history
so let's copy that down onto a new line
change this to com history and change
question to comore
history okay now let's come up to the
answer template and I'm just going to
make some changes here so I'm going to
say you can answer a given question
about scrimber based on the context
provided did and the conversation
history I'm going to leave this sentence
intact try to find the answer in the
context but I'm going to add in here if
the answer is not given in the context
find the answer in the conversation
history if possible now I think that's
going to work but again in the real
world we would have to do some testing
here try a few different ways of wording
this and just see what got us the
results that we wanted now let's come in
here and we'll just add the com history
okay it looks like we're done so so
let's come back up to the challenge and
it's just telling us to test it so let's
hit save and I'll say my name's Tom what
is
scrimber and it's given us an answer to
that question and now I'll ask it what
my name is and it says your name is Tom
so the memory is working and we have
successfully created a chatbot
knowledgeable about our document and
with a memory and that is a pretty
awesome thing to do when you remember
how Unthinkable this would have been
even just a couple of years years ago
let's just refresh and ask it one more
question and I'm going to ask it what is
the scrimba community
like and it says the scrimba community
is a global community of friendly and
helpful coders we believe in learning to
code as a community activity so we've
set up a Discord server where you can
meet fellow coders share your problems
and solutions and network and that is
actually very true and you can come and
hang out with us there so this project
is done congratulations on making it
through to the end and let's just take
one more scrim to recap what we've
learned well every question I've asked
it I'm happy with the results but that
won't always be the case so what can you
do when performance is not up to
standard well there are a few tweaks you
can make firstly you could go right back
to where we set up the original document
and you could alter the chunk size we
went for a chunk size of 500 characters
you could go larger if you think your
chatbot needs more context and you could
go smaller if you think it needs more
granularity you could also change the
overlap size we went for an overlap of
about 10% next you could look at the
number of chunks which are actually
retrieved and I did mention earlier that
we would say something about that so
let's quickly come over here to the
utils folder and find our retriever now
right here we've got this Vector store
as Retriever and we we can pass a number
in here and that will control how many
chunks we get back from the vector store
let's just see what's happening at the
moment if we head down to our chain and
in fact we want the retriever chain here
we are so let's just come in here and
I'm going to add in an arrow function
and log out what this retriever is
giving us now this is going to break the
app but if we just open up the console
and I'm going to ask any question now
down in the console we can see that
we've got four chunks let's come right
back here to the Retriever and I'm just
going to whack this up to 10 and I'll
ask a question and there we are we get
10 chunks down in the console and we
could of course take it down to as low
as one and we get one chunk now I'm
going to leave that empty so it defaults
to four I think that is absolutely fine
for this use case but do be aware of
that setting because it can be pretty
useful if you get more chunks you can
provide more context but if you feel
your answers are a bit vague and off
topic you might want to reduce that
number and just focus in on the best
quality chunks because remember the
retriever is going to give you the
closest matches first okay let's just
take that out of index.js because else
it's going to cause US problems now you
have got other options you can look to
prompt engineering so just come here to
where we've created our templates the
answer template the Standalone question
template and you can just think about
how you can tighten those up I think Al
promps are pretty good here but if you
find you're not getting the performance
you expect you can mix things up go into
more detail add some examples and just
experiment and see what you get now
lastly you shouldn't forget the open AI
settings again in index.js we've got the
llm setup right here and what we could
do of course is open this up and in here
we can use any open AI settings we want
so we've got for example temperature and
when working with your own knowledge bot
it might be a good idea to set that to
zero remember the higher the temperature
the more daring the AI gets and we don't
particularly want daring here we're not
trying to be creative so actually
setting that to zero might be a pretty
good idea now you could also change
which model you're using GPT 4 GPT 3.5
any other new model that comes out and
likewise here we've got access to
frequency penalty and presence penalty
and they might not be so relevant for
this use case but they are there if you
need to use them as well as any other
setting that you can use with the open
AI API so do be aware of that and you
can always come in here and change
things if you need to I'm of the opinion
that if it's not broken you don't need
to fix it so I'm actually going to leave
this exactly as it
was okay so those are five things that
you can look at if you're not getting
the performance you expect and so
hopefully that will be useful if you do
run into problems okay we're pretty much
done with this so let's just take one
more scrim to recap what we've
studied
ation on finishing this course you now
have a really strong foothold in the
world of Lang chain and you've got the
skills you need to build powerful
scalable AI applications quickly let's
just recap what we studied firstly we
used a text splitting tool from Lang
chain to split our documents into chunks
we created vectors for those chunks
using an open AI embeddings model we
then set up some templates and prompts
and we can see examples of those right
here when the prompts were ready to go
we chained them to large language models
and the string output passer using the
pipe method and again we can see an
example of that right here now those
were the more basic chains and we came
on to more complex chains a little bit
later but first we took the user's input
and vectorized it and then found the
closest matches from the chunks in our
Vector store we use those chunks to
generate the final answer and we chained
it all together using a runnable
sequence which is a really cool way to
build a more complex chain wow that was
quite a lot so why don't you head over
to our Discord Channel and go to the
today I did Channel this slide is a link
right through to that channel and brag
to the world about what you've achieved
and with that all that's left to say is
thank you very much for taking this
course do feel free to reach out to me
on Twitter at TP chant it is always good
to hear from you and always good to get
feedback and till next time good
luck